Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
our
class or our discussion, our reading of
Wajis
and discussing the Sunnah of the
prophet, our prophet, our messenger
sallall.aii Wasallam
with respect to wudoo
and we had arrived at the chapter
regarding
the times occasions instances in which
is preferred.
And so the authors mention a number of
things such as generally speaking wudoo
for every remembrance of Allah such as
wudoo before a person goes to sleep for
a person in a state of janaba and then
and we ended yesterday morning
discussing woo
at the start of making take ma making
and having made. Now
one of the issues that is so commonly
misconstrued misunderstood
is the nature of and its effects on
wudoo.
We've mentioned before that hadith
state of spiritual impurity
it is of two types. There is major
hadith
and minor hadith. Major hadith means a
person or major impurity means a person
needs to bathe in order to remove it.
Geneaba
after menration for women after
postpartum bleeding etc. You must bathe
in order for this to be removed
alleviated in order to make salah.
Minor hadith you just need.
Now as a general rule,
if a person
bathes to remove major hadith,
then minor hadith is removed as well.
What does that translate to? That means
that if a person is in a state of janaba
for instance
and
he wishes to pray does he have to take
makeul and then make wub to pray? No. He
merely makes
and the act of making
removes that major hadith
and by extension removes the minor
hadith with it.
And this is something that
was narrated to have taught the
companions, taught the
and to have driven this point home. And
that is the act that removes major
hadith will remove with it minor hadith.
And so if a person bathes
they do not have to make as a matter of
fact
explicitly said in
she positively says that the messenger
of Allah
wasallam would not bathe would excuse me
would not make wudoo after bathing. He
would not do that. That was not his
sunnah. His sunnah is that he would
bathe and then that is it. He would not
bathe and then after that make wudoo.
Now
notice the
caveat there. Notice the condition.
The condition is that the be for major
hadith
in order for it to count for
if it is for minor if it is for you know
just for let's say
a person is bathing because they bathe
every morning before they go to work or
they're bathing because they just got
home from the gym and they're sweaty and
they're right and so They're bathing to
clean themselves, but they're not in a
state of janaba. They're not in a state
of major hadith. Do they have to make
wudoo? Absolutely, they have to make
wudoo because only that is made as an
act of worship is what will what will
count towards a person's woo. And this
is a common common mistake.
When I was living in the Caribbean,
you know, we would go to the beach. I
mean, gosh, it's an island, right? So,
beaches everywhere.
And commonly when time for salah would
come around,
guys and gals would go into the water,
submerge themselves under the water, and
come back out and think that they have
woo.
Unless a person is in a state of janaba,
that will not count as woo. That doesn't
count as anything.
A person is commanded to make woo.
If a person bathes,
it still will not count as woo,
right? And we've mentioned this before.
Let's say a person a person is commanded
to wipe over their head in wudoo. If a
person were to wash their head,
which is more than wiping, right? Would
it count? Absolutely not.
But it's better. It's not what was
commanded. What was commanded is to is
to wipe over the head. This is an
important point. The only time
will count towards your woo is if that
is made in order to remove major hadith.
If you are in janaba for men that's the
only instance if you are in a state of
janaba
and for women if they are in a state of
janaba or if they are in a state of
you know after menration and so forth
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
if a person makes
to clean himself not for janaba but they
make it in the way that the prophet made
right so he made wudoo through it but
it's not for janaba do they have wudoo
absolutely because they made wudoo right
that's the point how did the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam make? Well,
we described, he would wash his
hands and then his private parts and
then he would make woo he would
make for salah. Then he'd pour the water
on his head three times and then his
right side and then his left side and
then his feet. We went over this
yesterday.
If a person bathes in this way and they
intended to have woo, they have voodoo.
But what is the bare minimum of? The
bare minimum of is that water completely
run over the entirety of a person's
body including their mouth and nose with
intention of this is
if a person does this do they have if
that was from janaba then yes they have
they have
because what removes the major hadith
will remove with it the minor hadith
And so, , it's very important to make
this distinction. I cannot
tell you how many if I had a dime, if I
had a niggle for every person that made
this mistake that I've met in my life
that made this confusion
that
asked me this question, I would be
I would have a sizable, you know, a
sizable a small fortune because this
is such Such a common misconception. You
would open a book in you would read that
says that if removes major hadith then
it removes minor hadith and if a person
makes they don't have to ba they don't
have to make and they don't
differentiate
between bathing which is worship and
bathing which is which is custom to to
clean yourself Right.
Subhanali.
[Silence]
Wasam.